foi tarde
é estou aqui eu não vou dizer que não
estou ansiosa está outra me criei várias
vezes não é muito muito bom muito
infelizmente estar aqui convosco
tudo porque o tema que traz cargas são
três paixões
uma delas é terapia sexual não acorda de
manhã vou nos dias em que a consulta não
é só consultar também fazer perseguição
é pensar em trabalho acordo com a
instituição do fagner situação da
companhia é de facto é uma aventura e é
um prazer imenso prazer é é a segunda
grande paixão é que está associada
também a primeira - pela forma como faça
terapia sexual tem a ver com ela
uma coisa que nem é relativamente nova
mas que felizmente começa a estar cada
vez mais a gente teve prosseguimento com
uma coisa que o que o joel falou que é
importante estar presente estarmos
presentes e presentes a cada momento na
nossa vida é um trailer em andamento é e
está em facto é uma importância brutal
para a nossa qualidade de vida para a
nossa alegria é e também é importante a
nível e sexual
a terceira grande paixão era uma paixão
partilhada ou não com um cada uma das
pessoas que está aqui presente vamos ver
se é é um dos quatro
provavelmente olharam para coisa que
receberam neste intervalo
não só isso ou não surgir alguns
pensamentos mas surgiram está cá dentro
preto branco grande será pequeno e será
que também importa
scliar para os mais gulosos como eu
provavelmente se estivermos bem atentos
ao nosso corpo que está acontecer se
calhar aqui ou aqui ou se calhar saque é
só levar
já a pensar na imagem dos quatro ter no
boca ou para quem não gosta de chocolate
scliar
nós também respondemos com o nosso corpo
e curiosamente nestas na nossa cultura
mais ocidental
nós funcionamos muito do pescoço para
cima e não entramos muito o corpo está
sempre presente está presente nas nossas
vivências incorpora ano memórias corpo é
extraordinário é fundamental jogar com
ele é que esse pensamento sexual que
algumas coisas também vai falar é tem
tudo porque julga ter um orgasmo este
tipo de opções está mais presente ano
sexuais
estou a falar daquelas que são os mais
frequentes ao nível da água é algo entre
25 e 40 por cento das mulheres
portuguesas incluídas que têm problemas
de muitos problemas a nível do orgasmo
problemas a nível da dor quando falamos
das masculinas falamos há cura mas
também de modo parecido que é curioso ou
não é de um homem que é terrível porque
pra mim é complicado não teve rivais
prometem mais ainda porque nós temos uma
sociedade e uma traição
a tam é que ele traça caminhos muito
estreito com dois treinos para a
sexualidade masculina é o homem tem que
tem que ser um super macho latino tem
que estar sempre pronto
é tem que funcionar é mesmo a tradição
judaico cristã está entrar nisso é uma
país mais marcel e neymar precisa tá
entanto a mulher tem que ser essa casta
é o desejo sexual vêm muito associado a
culpa também quer mais é essa
começa é é responder a outra moda
alimentada pelos média não mídias andré
é que é esta noção de que nós temos que
ser super ser super sexuais
isto é tem que ter orgasmos fantástico
extraordinário que a mulher pode ter
orgasmos múltiplos
sim nós ao contrário dos homens e esta é
ter um dois três quatro
tivemos 45 é melhor do que ter um outro
que não está completamente satisfeita
não é que marca mas continuamos com este
discurso é para o orgasmo simultâneo em
seu auge do prazer também não tem nada
vez nessa
mas há pessoas que são mais vulneráveis
que envolvem de facto é uma problemática
sexual é o que a fia sexual faz nestas
situações há vários tanto é transexual é
uma arte
o mar tem tanto vários ingredientes
digamos assim em função de uma lesão
específica de cada caso específico cada
problemáticas específicas
usamos mais ou menos ingredientes e modo
geral é que está provado que tem
eficácia elevada eficácia são os focos
sensoriais são convites aos casais para
fazerem brincadeiras digamos mais
focadas nas sensações exigente
ligamos e é os genitais são excluídos
numa primeira fase a informação ea
educação
fazem parte também no sentido de ajudar
a desmistificar a reestruturação
cognitiva é também é fundamental e de
comunicação precisam - a casais precisam
de outros ingredientes têm sido
fantásticos tem sido a introdução da
terapia sexual dessas técnicas de
treinar a mente para estar no aqui e no
agora a autocompaixão são importadas
entre do oriente funcionam como forma de
nos devolver o único tempo espaço que
efetivamente temos que agora nós não
temos mais a ilusória
de resto a ideia de que amanhã ontem
amanhã estou viva na facção é trazem é
bastante os benefícios ao nível da da
sexualidade não quero passar uns com
informação é acerca de estudos
informação é muito macio méxico é também
importante apoiarmos na ciência e nos
dados da investigação para perceber o
que funciona eo que não funciona
em 2008 foi feito um estudo é em que com
apenas três sessões do grupo é realizada
ao longo do trecho semanas onde foram
incorporadas em várias áreas técnicas
informações sempre que a educação é
tetra mas também exercícios específicos
de mais informação atenção plena é e
foram usados com mulheres que tinham
tanto antigo é cair necrológico e é
triste mas depois com estas sessões
grupo de 90 minutos é e prática em casa
do crime atualmente tem que ser
praticado
estas mulheres movimento do ponto de
vista físico ajuda foi feito através da
intervenção tanto a nível do cancro mas
é em termos de humor
tanta pressão o gol completamente estava
bastante mais aliviada em termos de
interesse e desejo sexual que tenham
pedido foi comprado e mostrar uma maior
capacidade de aceitar os seus corpos
diferentes mas após as intervenções
cirúrgicas e um à vontade em conforto
com seu corpo nunca antes tinham motivo
que é extraordinário é mesmo isto foi
aplicada em 30 em alguns meses depois
como é que só tenham problemas de soja
em algumas delas tenham sido vítimas de
abuso sexual e não só a tanto reportavam
no final maiores níveis de desejo da
excitação do capacidade para ligar com o
corpo e perceberam que estão a sentir o
momento a momento isso fato é é a chave
para o prazer
como também é aumentar as situações de
abuso estavam muito mais à vontade tanto
aquelas assembléia a culpa e outras
opções que estão associadas estava
completamente diferente de tudo que foi
feito é este fundo com pessoas que já
praticavam a meditação há cerca de 20
anos sabe que é muito tempo
é o que se verificou foi que é o nível
de ambição com o parceiro era quase
instantâneo
não vou dizer que não era preciso haver
má notícia mas não era precisa vir facto
é coisa extraordinária do ponto de vista
físico para haver uma ligação profunda
com o outro com outra é isso que aliás
estágios fato alguns alguns ensinamentos
é e proposição as mensagens que são
andré veiculadas nós vamos a uma bomba
de gasolina e vemos vista ver como
aumentar os seus orgasmos como é ser a
promoção digamos desta sexualidade mais
exigente e condicional parece triste
regras também para a sexualidade é e
proposição o cinto de estágio aqui e no
agora estar disponível primeiro que tudo
pra mim próprio pra mim própria bairro é
ligar um conquistar acontecer neste
momento comigo é é um facilita e cria
espaço para estar também com o outro de
uma outra maneira muito mais disponível
temos uma indicação errada acerca do
tempo
não sei como é que isto tem tudo bem
é um carinho sobre os exercícios que são
feitos no âmbito de protocolos de alguns
edifícios que são particularmente
interessantes alguns não são assim tão
fáceis quanto isso podemos sentar com
vocês tão grande que 20 minutos e
simplesmente observado observar não só
para o fundo pode ser sentar e ver como
é que eu estou que está a passar comigo
neste momento não quero ficar na sua
própria experiência
o primeiro pensamento consurso
consigo chutar o ar que entra o arte sai
o intervalo entre cada inspiração e cada
inspiração se lutar os movimentos do meu
corpo se acha criação fazer isto durante
um segundo nos fundos três sonhos é
fácil fazer isso em cinco minutos é
brutal tudo bem tudo nós estamos
habituados que até é estar em modo de
função e passar para o modo de ser e
estar
é difícil difícil é não vamos fazer nem
haveria tempo para propor fazer aqui é
um exercício muito muito longo
há vários exercícios podem site
atualmente é feito é quando se
introduzem tanto estas técnicas não é
propriamente uma técnica que passa a ser
uma outra forma que está é um exercício
com passas não são aquelas passas e
curvas passa é eu não sou propriamente
fé por isso é mesmo apaixonada por
chocolate então uso habitualmente o
convite e agora era para esta coisa que
eu e não é simplesmente deixaram
envolver com a experiência pode ser
então é cada uma seu ritmo e pedir que
desligassem e se este objeto esta coisa
vamos ficar com uma coisa despida nas
mãos
e existe sim a tentação do inter logo a
boca que fazemos habitualmente com quase
tudo e não fizeram pois não há castigo a
que instigam a história fosse uma coisa
tântrica mas não é o tema da festa minha
separação que nós agora vamos passar à
ação que acontece por aqui também não
sai anos vez que vamos ver então livre
que observar é esta coisa que temos à
frente observar a forma e virando ver
curso a textura vice tem só uma coroa em
diferentes cores
no olímpico o companheiro do lado está
mesmo a experiência só para cada um
o meu trator partido que é fantástico
porque nós podemos temos esta capacidade
extraordinária
podemos também vez com as mãos e não
podemos fazer exercícios deixar o olho
tanto a quem se sentir confortável
naturalmente não eu convivi herói és
calma e tentar se ver com a ponta dos
dedos rolar mesmo este objeto esta coisa
que nós temos aqui a coisa tá aqui é ser
tentar ver se há alguma irregularidade
ou se é mais juízo
se calhar algumas mãos mais 500 estado
ter como é que fica essa sensação antes
que isto começa a passar para outra
linha
podemos tentar um com crianças
a primeira vez que eu vou ver esta coisa
nesse caso cheirar a distância daqui é
daqui e tem podemos ir mais longe para
marina e disse sair é igual com esta
menina com esta menina
podemos ir ainda mais longe
ela podemos e ainda mais nós e tentar
ver se é possível ouvir isso então
pixina sem que nenhum chocolate um ato e
para o outro equipe mesmo silêncio que
não conseguem ouvir e que aproximassem
do voz ouvido um sabe se uma espécie de
cliq cliq e agora sim podem cada um
podia mesmo favor fiquem na vossa
experiência etapas queda 1 explorar o
primeiro na ponta da língua os claro o
nosso ritmo eu não vou dar mais
instruções prometo não é uma malandrice
ainda vai as que têm vez
como é que na ponta da língua quando o
empurrão o pedacinho declarou ontem
carlos mota em casa
como é que é nem por um dos quatro codu
mais para trás a chegar completamente
também podem haver naturalmente aí união
escrever críticas à a aaa
peter hoy minha cara é esperam e
sinceramente sã e esta é mesmo a minha
paixão espero que em pequenino
específico é fácil com o chocolate fosse
transportado por outras circunstâncias
tão simples como beber um copo d'água
comer uma maçã ou tomar um banho ou
lavar os dentes ou outras coisas disse
deixou critério muito obrigada pela
vossa atenção